how's it going bros my name is peter pan
welcome to buy weed stuff online with
our first guest of the shower welcome
everyone you're sitting on in here I
like your style good job
so you brought in the first item of this
week yes you did
look underneath your feet dig deeper
your junior sophisticates Richie wait
what is this crazy item you have brought
what what is this oh my god what is it
it's for if if you're tired on an
airplane and you want to sleep you put
it on and then you can sleep in kids you
want to scratch you comfortable and if
you need to eat you just turn it this
way and
what is it it's ah it's bonus turtle
from this turtle what have you brought
for us for you
bonus turtle let's get blisters with
blow up emergency blow up kids thank you
thank you
Thank You turtle that is you okay so we
have one each oh my god oh man this
ain't no teenage girl
I said what are you doing what might
said Obama what are you doing here Bama
it's a really creepy mask I haven't seen
it on other people
all right clap it up for the next start
of the show hi um I'm Bernadette
Cumberbatch why don't you find early
cumberbatch would you like to present
the last item yes
all right the final item of this week's
find oneself online is a mouth open air
oh it's a mouth feeder it's from Japan I
do not explain don't don't feed it hey
Darrell how you doing
all right that was fine wage stuff
online thank you myself of being the
first guest of this show here comes a
kiss from Cumberbatch himself
I'm Cumberbatch I'm gonna kiss you I
love you um come here my name is obscure
welcome is that how he does it